aujourd'hui saigon macao hong kong
volcan de fûts matra survol dantès
et on approche de saïda
saigon fidèle à ce que les français en
ont fait la plus belle ville l'extrême
orient sampan mollement bercy sur la
rivière
50 servent au début
vous tapez une fois et regardez bien le
capitaine de ce frêle navires et une
femme au sens fort heureusement
perpétuellement dans le mouvement
et maintenant rapide voyage dans les
arts y'as lra
paysages qui peut paraître insolite
d'allonger ce prix européen
e
il ya beaucoup d'optimisme
on va regarder bien sûr comme mon cas ma
tête
et voilà bah d'un point à un autre par
une voie d'eau après si on se baigne a
fléchi mais
le chien il n'apprécie pas du tout va
faire chaud venu
des ménages aussi en barque
fini les pêcheurs et sèche en attendant
de rêver et surgissant soudain cette
pagode de ce type mais
voyez vous les yeux les deux yeux à la
vente se sent pas eh bien ils sont
destinés à faire peur à ma couille le
diam le village de costa
bouh
sur pilotis
et maintenant anbar co pour macao sur
cette mère célèbre par six pirates
contre lesquelles on protège les bateaux
par des grillages mais malin comme des
singes certains pirates mans d'abord
comme passager et attaque le bateau en
coordination avec des jaunes qui évolue
tout autour manche eu des dons et l on
prendre un peu de poisson
fisette est minuscule côté du filet jeu
et derrière ses filets on se tient une
partie de la flotte de haute mer le
matin
moi si
45 degrés à l'ombre ce qui explique
cette piscine et surtout surtout besoin
de s'y plonger
et pourtant
vasco de gama soit
en 14 18 de nombreux volontaires ont
quitté macao pour venir combattre sur le
front français
un certain nombre d'entre eux hélas ne
sont pas revenus est un monument
rappelle leur sacrifice
et visitons macao est une ville très
dense
pour une étoile
à travers les vieilles rues de la ville
chinoise nous sommes arrivés à cette
façade elle semble suspendu c'est une
église portugaise que le feu a détruit
il ya de nombreux siècles
mais bientôt il va nous falloir embarqué
et nouveau traversons la maison vient
meilleur que le soleil pour sécher le
poisson est là bas grâce au sang pendant
la crise du logement est totalement
résolue vous voyez les grilles dont je
vous parlais tout à l'heure ce sont
celles qui protégeront les bateaux
contre l'assaut des pirates
au revoir à maintenant
et quant à ce grillage lui il protège
les passagers de cabine ou contre ceux
des ponts car il pourrait avoir partie
liée avec des gaillards montant des
jonques rapide mais prudent le capitaine
s'en remet à un bouddha
la coutume veut que ce soit un bouddha
guerrier et qui lui brûle de l'encens
pour acheter sa continuité
de macao a hong kong la mer rouge ap
sillonné de long et plus et hong kong
les petits garçons chinois ne sont pas
difficiles et les marges aux nattes
deviennent de joyeux spithill
malheureusement pour ces charmants
canard cela risque de mal finir
en effet ils vont rapidement si j'ose
dire passer à la casserole de dix
manières différentes
et voici le sort dramatique réservé à
branche chinoise la famille de donald
duck là bas même les canards sont là tu
es ce sont des oiseaux cru c'est une
spécialité
et autres joyaux bien vivant ceci
ramener désir a mené par des marins ils
pourront des jours heureux à anvers ou à
hambourg
loin des enseignes de hong kong et de
leurs idéogrammes indéchiffrable
on
e
les marchés en plein vent offre jour et
nuit les produits appétissant ou
inquiétant d'une cuisine qui ne recule
devant un grand chose là bas vous
mangerez du sert quand free de l'aileron
de requin et même des souris confites et
miel que l'amateur aval d'une bouchée
commune olives farcies
c'est toujours ça
ce fils du ciel qu'à sa croûte d'une
façon bien chinois ces petits
restaurants servent 50 plats différents
de quoi sont-ils composé mystère
quelquefois peut-être vaut-il mieux ne
pas le savoir dès leur plus jeune âge
les enfants chinois
accroché sur le dos de leurs mères
prennent l'habitude de considérer les
chose d'assez haut
c'est peut-être une explication de la
possibilité de la sagesse orientale
au milieu de ces visage énigmatique à
travers ses vignes se côtoient
l'opulence et la misère
cette ville qui est le symbole du choc
des races qui se bousculent pour une
place au soleil
bien des questions se posent à
l'observateur une d'abord quel sera
l'avenir de support surpeuplée seul
trait d'union autorisé par la chine
rouge entre elle et le monde occidental
énormes enjeux posés sur le têt misère
de la politique mondiale